- My talk is on logical causal inference,
truth, counterfactual
scope, and invariance.
So where is the...
Okay, in his webpage, Zenna Tavares
whose webpage I looked
at before this conference
says, "I want to understand
how humans reason,
how they come to derive
knowledge from observing
and interacting with the world."
And this is also what
I want to understand.
And in this talk I will
pursue this interest
by examining two types of
inference that are often thought
to be very different from each other.
Logical inference and causal inference.
Logical inference, allegedly,
has nothing to do with the world.
Causal inference has everything
to do with the world.
I will examine the nature
of these inferences
by using three parameters.
One, truth in the strong
sense of factual truth
or truth in the world,
not linguistic truth
or coherentist truth, or pragmatist truth.
And counterfactual scope, and invariance.
My result will be one,
contrary to expectations,
logical and causal inferences are similar
with respect to truth in the world.
Two, they are different with
respect to counterfactual scope
and invariance, but only in degree.
Truth.
Logic is usually thought
to have nothing to do
with the world, hence
with truth in the world.
Logic is said to be analytic,
i.e. based on language
or meaning regardless of how the world
happens to be or necessarily is.
The logical inference, and here I use same
kind of inference as Alex,
one, Pa or Pb, not Pa,
therefore Pb is of the same kind
as the linguistic inference,
A is a bachelor, therefore A is unmarried.
And different in kind from
Hume's relevant example
of a causal inference.
A hit B, therefore B moved,
where A and B are say, billiard balls.
Now influence three, A
hit B, therefore B moves,
depends on the way the world is
and a certain regularity
in the world, as Hume said,
a connection in the
world between two events.
But the common view is
one and two don't depend
on the way the world is.
They don't depend on any
regularity in the world.
They depend on the way our language is,
and the meaning of words,
and a conventional connection
between words in our language, CARNAP,
or on the language game
we happen to be playing, Wittgenstein.
Now all three inferences,
the logical, the linguistic,
and the causal, guarantee the transmission
of truth from the premises to conclusion.
That's why they are inferences.
Indeed, they guarantee
the transmission of truth
in the world from premises to conclusion.
Assuming the premises
are true in the world,
the conclusion is guaranteed
to be true in the world.
But while the transmission of
truth in the causal inference
is due to a connection between
things or event in the world,
the transmission of truth
in the linguistic inference
is due to a connection
between words in our language,
bachelor and unmarried.
And the view is the transmission of truth
in the logical inference
is also thought to be true
due to a connection between words.
And this view, the correctness
of A is a bachelor,
therefore A is unmarried,
is due to a connection
between its non-logical
words, bachelor and unmarried,
and the correctness of
the logical inference,
Pa or Pb, not Pa, therefore
Pb, is due to a connection
between its logical words, or and not.
But does this mean that one is grounded
only or mainly in language?
The sentence says in the inference,
in the logical inference, say
something about the world.
The first premise says that
in the world, at least one
of the two individuals, A and B,
is in P, or has the property P.
The second premise says that in the world
A is in the compliment of P.
And the conclusion says that
in the world, B is in P.
Now the logical words or
symbols in this inference
could have meant something
different from what they mean.
If negation meant affirmation,
the inference would not have been valid.
But that would not change the fact
that in the world there is a connection
between at least one X and Y is in P,
and X is in the compliment
of P, and Y is in P.
This is a connection in the world.
And it is this connection in the world
rather than our linguistic conventions
or the language game we happen to play
that is responsible for the
logical validity of one.
In this way, the logical
validity of Pa or Pb,
not Pa, therefore Pb, is similar in kind
to the causal validity of
A hit B, therefore B moved.
They are due to certain
regularities that hold in the world.
A causal regularity in the case of three.
A formal regularity in the case of one.
It is for this reason the truth
in the world is transmitted
from premises to conclusions
both in one and in two.
So, not only are the
sentences of one and three
true or false in the
strong sense of being true
or false in the world,
their inferential power
is due to relevant regularities
or connections in the world.
This is further seen by
the fact that no relevant
regularities or connections
exist in that when no relevant
exist in the world,
the corresponding inferences are invalid.
For example, since in the
world there is no regular
connection between billard
ball A being stationary
and billard ball B moving,
the inference A is stationary
therefore A is moving, is
invalid causal inference.
Similarly, since in the
world there is no connection
between one, at least one
of X and Y being in P,
and X being in P, as you
can see in the picture,
and two, Y being in the complement of P,
the inference Pa or
Pb, this is a different
from the original, Pa, therefore not Pb
is not logically valid.
It is a game.
It could be an inferential
game, but it's not valid.
There's nothing in the world
that connects the two parts.
Let us see a case in which
accepting an inference
like 1 prime, that's Pa or
Pb, Pa, therefore not Pb.
An influence that fails in the world
and acting upon it can bring
about death in the world,
and not just losing a game.
Suppose A and B are mushrooms.
P means poisonous.
And in the world mushroom B is poisonous.
This is compatible with the premises
of both the valid logical argument, one,
and the invalid game argument one prime.
Pa or Pb, at least one is poisonous.
And A is not poisonous.
We didn't say anything about A,
or A is poisonous being true.
But while the game inference
one prime gives us license
to eat mushroom B, it
says it's not poisonous,
that will kill us.
The worldly inference one does not.
There is a life and death
difference between one
which is grounded in the world,
and one prime which is grounded
in a convention or a game.
And the same holds in
other cases, just as using
an incorrect aerodynamic
laws in building an airplane
can cause the airplane to crash,
so using incorrect logical
laws in designing an airplane
can cause it to crash.
Once I played a game of
creating a logic in which,
when you give instruction
lift you get drag,
when you give drag you get lift
because the logic tells you to do so.
Conclusion.
Logical inferences like
causal inferences are based
on regularities in the world.
Physical regularities in the
case of causal inferences,
formal regularities in the
case of logical inferences.
Two, counterfactual or modal scope.
We have seen that logical and
causal inferences are similar
with respect to truth in the world.
Next, let us turn to their counterfactual
scope or modal force.
Inferences are divided
into weak, material,
and stronger, non-material.
Weak, here we go from
premises to conclusion
and there's only very weak requirement.
It cannot be the case that
all the premises are true
and the conclusion is false,
where truth means true,
actually true in the
actual world, no more.
No requirement of
irregularity in the world
that connects the premises
to the conclusion.
For example, here is an example
of a material inference.
San Diego is in California,
therefore New Haven is in Connecticut.
This is materially correct
because the consequence,
the conclusion is correct, is true,
and there's no regularity in the world.
That's material inference.
Causal and logical
inferences are stronger.
They require regularity,
indeed a stronger regularity,
one that includes counterfactual cases.
Hence inferences have
counterfactual scope.
Thus A hit B, therefore
B moved, holds not only
for actual billard balls
but also for counterfactual billard balls.
Pa or Pb, not Pa, therefore
Pb holds not just for actual
mushrooms but also for
counterfactual mushrooms.
Both have counterfactual scope
but do they have the same scope?
And if not, why not?
I'm not looking for an answer
that relies on our intuitions.
I usually don't believe in intuitions.
I'm looking for a theoretically
systematic, precise,
informative, and correct answer.
To arrive at such an answer
I return to invariance.
And to make the answer more informative
I will move to new examples.
In particular, I would
like to use an example
of a logical inference that
has a richer logical structure
and an example of a causal inference
that is related to a general law of nature
such as Newton's law of gravitation.
My examples will be five,
for some X Px or not,
or QX, for all X, not Qx,
therefore for some X Px.
Somewhat similar, but we
have here quantification.
Something is P or Q, nothing is Q,
therefore something is P.
Six, some kind of inference
from gravity to motion.
For example, gravity causes the free fall
of objects near the surface of the earth.
I will show that five, the
logical inference is based
on a connection in the world
between properties that have
maximal degree of invariance
and this means that it
itself has a maximal
counterfactual scope, and that
means that it has a maximal
modal force that is necessity.
I will also show that
six, the causal inference
is based on a connection in
the world between properties
that have non-maximal invariance.
Therefore they have non-maximal,
although significant,
counterfactual scope and
non-maximal, yet significant,
modal force or necessity.
Invariance.
Invariance is a central topic
of interest both in science
and in logic and mathematics.
There are many types of invariance.
For example invariance of laws of nature
and the replacements
of frames of reference.
Here I will focus on
invariance of properties
and the replacements of individuals.
To prevent misunderstanding,
let me clarify that
I use the term property
in its everyday sense,
not as a philosophical term
of art, such as universal,
and I'm also not interested
in the ontological status
of properties here.
What I say here is compatible
with different ontological
accounts of properties.
Now, properties in general
are selective in nature.
They distinguish between
some objects but not all.
Example, the property is a human
distinguishes between me and my laptop,
but not between me and Alex,
or between my laptop and the number one.
Neither of them have this property,
so it doesn't distinguish between them.
The property is a woman does distinguish
between me and Alex, but
not between me and Priya,
or between Alex and the number one.
I will say that is a human is invariant
and the replacements of me by Alex
and of, say Mount Everest by
one, but not by a replacement
of me or Alex by one or Everest.
In general, a first level
property P is invariant
under replacements of
individuals that have it
by individuals that have
it, and by individuals
that don't have it by
individuals that don't have it,
but not by individuals that have it
by an individuals that don't have it.
So this is very general and simple.
More precisely, I will talk
about invariance of properties
under one-to-one
replacements of individuals.
Or if I take domains into
account under one-to-one,
and onto replacements of individuals.
For example in the domains,
Gila, Alex, and the
number one, one domain.
And second, Pria, my
laptop, and Mount Everest,
Is a woman is invariant
under the one-to-one
and onto replacement R,
which goes from me to Priya,
and from Alex to my laptop,
and from Everest to the number one,
but not under the one-to-one
and onto replacement,
our prime, that goes from me to my laptop,
from Alex to one, and
from Everest to Priya.
That is only a replacement
that lead us from things
that are women to things that are women,
or things that are not women
to things that are not women.
Now we are ready to proceed
to maximal invariance.
Maximal invariance.
While the properties we
looked at so far are invariant
under some are the properties...
Okay, while the properties we
looked at so far are invariant
under some one-to-one
and onto replacements,
they are not invariant under all.
But some properties are
invariant under all one-to-one
and onto replacements of individuals.
These properties are maximally invariant.
Example, is identical to.
Take any individual's, A B,
and replace them by any
individuals in a one-to-one manner.
You replace A by RA and B by RB.
It is easy to see that
identity is preserved.
A is identical to B if, and
only if, RA is identical to RB.
If we have equinumerous domains,
this holds across domains
where R is one-to-one and onto.
So identity is maximally invariant.
The second level property non-emptiness
or non-empty is also maximally invariant.
This property is the property denoted
by the existential quantifier.
When we say. for some X PX, what we say is
that the property P is not
empty, so the denotation
of the existential quantifier
is the second level
property is non-empty.
Now take any two equinumerous domains,
D1 and D2, take any one-to-one
and onto replacement
R from D1 to D2.
Take any first level property P and D1,
and look at the image
of P, P prime under R.
It is easy to see that
P is non empty in D one,
If, and only if, its image
under one-to-one replacements
of the individuals is non empty in D2.
So is non-empty is also
maximally invariant.
And we have the result, one.
All the logical properties,
that is those that are denoted
by the logical constants such as identity,
complementation in a given domain denoted
by negation in a context like Px,
intersection, union,
inclusion, non-emptiness,
and universality in a given domain,
they are all maximally invariant.
Second result, no physical properties
are maximally invariant.
One way to see that is to note
that they are not invariant
under one-to-one and onto
replacements of physical
individuals by mathematical individuals.
For example, numbers.
All physical individuals are subject
to gravity but numbers are not,
and similarly for all
other physical properties.
Next result.
Maximal invariance entails
large counterfactual scope
which entails strong necessity.
Maximal invariance of
property entails stronger
counterfactual scope of
inferences based on them
then of inferences based on non-maximally
invariant properties.
It follows from this
result, counterfactual scope
of logical inferences is
greater than the counterfactual
scope of causal inferences.
But the difference between them
is only a matter of degree.
Now let me explain this, or
show that this is the case.
Let us first explain this
result by means of an example,
and then theoretically.
The logical inference we
had before, for some X, PX
or QX, for all X not QX,
therefore for some X PX,
is logically valid because in the world
the non emptiness, existential
quantifier, of the union,
this junction, of two
properties and the emptiness
of the second, for all X not, is connected
by a formal regularity
to the non-emptiness
of the first property.
Now this holds in all
actual counterfactual
domains of individuals,
that is in all domains
of either actual or
counterfactual individuals.
Therefore, the counterfactual
scope of this inference,
hence its model scope, is very high.
Another way to represent this
on the level of the world,
the lowest level, where we look at actual
and counterfactual individuals,
we have irregularity,
a formal regularity or law,
non-emptiness of the union
of P and Q, and emptiness of Q guarantees,
or brings about, or
necessitates non-emptiness of P.
This ensures that on the
level of truth, the truth
of the two premises guarantees
the truth of the conclusion.
And this guarantees that
the inference for some X, PX
or QX for all X not QX,
therefore for some X PX
is logically valid.
This explains why the above inference
transmits truth from
premises to conclusions,
and does so with a strong necessity.
A note on the scope of
maximally invariant properties
and inferences based on that.
Logical or formal properties
do not distinguish
between individuals that
are physically possible
and physically impossible.
From their point of view,
there's no difference between them.
And even between individuals
that are metaphysically
possible and metaphysically impossible.
Example.
From a formal or logical perspective,
a ball that is both all red
and blue is just as possible
and just as subject to formal
and logical regularities
as a ball that is both all red and small.
From the point of view of
the logical properties,
there's no difference between
being all red and blue,
and being all red and small.
It simply doesn't, it abstracts
from all such differences.
Therefore the counterfactual
scope of logical inferences
includes individuals that
are both all red and blue.
This is not the case
for causal inferences,
which are based on connections
that apply to domains
of actual counterfactual
physical individuals,
but not to other kinds of individuals.
Question.
But how exactly is maximal
invariance connected
to maximal necessity?
Answer.
If a property does not distinguish
between two individuals,
the laws or regularities
governing or describing it
cannot distinguish between them either.
Otherwise, it'll not be a law
or regularity of this property.
They apply to one if, and only
if, they apply to the other.
Now, if P is a maximally
invariant property,
it does not distinguish
between any individuals actual
or counterfactuals, where
the scope of counterfactual
is broader than physical
counterfactuality.
Therefore, the scope of
the laws or regularities
governing describing TP is
also broader than the scope
of physical laws regularities
and the inferences
based on them are also very strong.
Now, what about causal inferences
and the laws regularities grounding them?
Take the inferences be
from gravity to motion
that we mentioned earlier.
While the property is subject to gravity,
some gravity, greater or smaller,
is not maximally invariant
in the actual counterfactual
sphere associated
with logical and formal properties.
It is maximally invariance
in the smaller actual
counterfactual sphere of
physically possible individuals.
All physical individuals,
actual and counterfactual,
are subject to gravity.
In contrast, the property is a human,
or is a homosapient, is
not maximally invariant
in the physical sphere.
For that reason, inferences
grounded in laws regularity
governing or describing gravity
have a stronger counterfactual
scope than inferences
grounded in laws regularity governing
or describing humanity.
But weaker than logical
inferences, which are grounded
in formal or logical
laws and regularities.
So logical inference are
strongest, maximal invariance,
maximally necessary.
Physical inferences and physical
laws have a lower degree
of invariance, lower degree of necessity.
But they can still have
a significant degree
of necessity such that the laws of gravity
or inferences based on these regularities,
and others too, can have
some counterfactual scope,
but a smaller one.
Conclusion.
Both logical and causal
or physical inferences
are grounded in certain
laws regularities that hold
of some actual counterfactual individuals.
Therefore both have a certain modal force.
But due to the fact that
logical inferences are grounded
in laws regularities that
govern or describe maximally
invariant properties,
while causal inferences
are grounded in laws regularities
that govern or describe
non-maximally invariant properties,
the counterfactual, hence modal
scope of logical inferences
is greater than that of causal inferences.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- [Announcer] We have
time for some questions.
If there are questions from
people who haven't asked yet,
I'll take those first.
If not, please stand and-
- [Participant 1] Yes,
thank you very much.
I was wondering if you
could say something more
about the counterfactual
mushroom, as an example.
- Okay.
The counterfactual,
let me give you sort of a another example.
I happen to have two children.
Now, it is, I could have had three.
And I could have said,
and there is a sense
in which it is true to say
that my third counterfactual,
the person who is the
third counterfactual child
is a counterfactual child of mine.
I think that in general when we talk,
and we always talk about
counterfactual situations
and counterfactual object,
counterfactual things.
Should I build this
machine or that machine?
If I build this one and not this,
this is a counterfactual machine
that maybe I could have built.
Now I think that it's very
important to understand,
to take into account
counterfactual objects
when you want to understand properties.
Why?
First, for some properties you
they have different degrees
of invariance, they distinguish
between different things
and so there are difference.
This is a significant
difference between them.
But in the actual world they may not.
I think Kelin likes the
example of has a heart
and has a kidney, or something like this.
It just so happens that
in the actual world,
if we take into account
only actually individuals,
they have the same invariances.
But if you want to understand
the difference between them,
you have to go beyond it.
But even more than that,
if you take the property
of gravity for example, in
order to understand gravity,
we have to understand that
had earth had another moon,
a counterfactual moon,
it would also be subject
to gravity by earth.
And we cannot understand gravity I think,
well if we don't understand that.
And so in general, in order
to understand properties,
and then the laws that govern them,
we have to understand
how they would behave
if something that is not
the case, were the case.
So that's where I get to
counterfactual objects
and including a counterfactual mushroom.
(Announcer speaking indistinctly)
- [Participant 2] So in
in my everyday experience
and at the experience of people I know,
quite often inferences come after delay.
You look at or work on something,
think about something, nothing works.
You wake up in the
morning, brush your teeth,
and here's an answer.
What mechanism does it involve?
It's clearly not a causal,
or it's not language related.
What mechanism involves there?
And a broader question.
I mean I appreciate this
logic, it's all logical,
but what kind of mechanisms humans use
to come up with inferences?
- Okay, yeah. So I think
both the question you asked
are for me, they are connected.
I think that knowledge
in general depends both
on how the world is, and
on how our mind works.
We can only know the world
through the prism of our mind,
of our cognitive resources.
And so in the case of inferences
that you talked about,
as a result of undergoing
this complex situation
in which we both look in the world
and use all our cognitive resources
and come to know the
world better and better,
we can see connections
between things in the world.
And it is seeing the connection
between different things
in the world that lead
us to make inferences
about the subject matter.
Sometimes the connection we see are formal
and then the inferences will
be logical or mathematical.
Sometimes the connection
we'll see is like a connection
between taking aspirin
and fever going down.
And then we will realize that in the world
there's a connection
between certain components
of these two phenomena,
and we draw an inference.
And so generally, I
think, when we look at it,
going to your second question,
how do we get to inferences?
So, the way I look at it is this.
I mean, human wants to
know the world as it is,
but we have many limitations.
We make mistakes.
Our cognitive capacities are limited.
So we need something that distinguishes
between correctness and incorrectness.
So, we introduce the concept of truth.
And we also have limited time.
We cannot always just
establish individually
every statement we want to establish.
So we look for shortcuts,
and inferences are shortcuts.
In inferences, it's enough
to establish the premise
and establish the
connection to other things.
And then you get the conclusion
and you don't have to
examine it separately.
And I think that humans
have the ability to detect
formal regularities in the world.
For example, they can see,
if you take some physical
properties, some properties are reflexive.
That's a formal feature of a property.
Some are symmetric, some are
transitive, some are not.
And you can see that
if you have a property
which is transitive, it
doesn't have to be symmetric.
But if you have a property
which is both symmetric
and reflexive and the universe is limited,
you can get transitivity.
And so we can figure
out formal connections
between properties,
we can figure out cardinality connections.
We can say that for
example, the cardinality
of people in this room
is maybe, I don't know,
30, 40, something like this.
Not zero, not 100.
And we can draw connections between 40
and cardinality 20 and say that the first
is larger than the second, and so on.
And so we observe
regularities in the world
including formal regularities.
And I think that's how we
get to logical inferences,
and we observe regularities in general
or connections in general,
and that's how we get to
other kinds of inferences.
- [Announcer] We can take one more.
Naftali was first, and
then we will need to stop.
But those of you who want to stay and talk
a little bit more, we
have time before dinner.
Naftali, (faintly speaking).
- [Naftali] Yes, thanks
so much for your talk.
So I like the notion
of maximal invariance,
but I'm still having a really
hard time wrapping my head
around formal irregularities.
Especially the notion
of formal irregularities
being something in the world.
And maybe one way to put
the thing that I'm...
Yeah sort of a bit bothered
by is you, you might think
that actually maximum
invariance would actually
count against formal
irregularities being in the world.
I mean, the thought just
being is that if these logical
truth could apply to a
totally fictional world,
or even a world that's, you know...
I mean it sort of seems to
take away from the notion
that these are actually in
the world in some sense.
So I dunno if I'm just
begging the question
and you know, adopting what would take
to be the more traditional
view about logical truths
being true in virtue of form.
But it still attracts me,
and maybe you could help me.
- Okay, so first let me say something
about formal irregularities in the world.
First, perhaps I will
mention another result,
which is an interesting
result, not obvious.
It turns out that all higher
level mathematical properties
are maximally invariant.
But aside from identity and a few others,
all first order, lower level
mathematical properties
and mathematical individuals
are not maximally invariant.
Now this is relevant to how
we think about the formal.
Today we very often
think about the formal,
the mathematical as first level.
And we think about individuals 1, 2, 3,
and we can say, well we have no evidence
for their being in the world,
and so we need to be Platonist
in order to accept that,
and we don't want it.
Let's just go with the
linguistic interpretation
of mathematics and logic and so on.
But now what I'm talking about
is mostly properties of properties.
Even if you start just
with physical individuals,
you are human.
And even you start just with
their physical properties,
it is a fact that in the
same way that in this room,
this room has the feature
that there are men in it
and women in it.
They also has the feature that
there are 40 humans in it,
rather than a million or zero.
It's just effect.
And it's a formal fact
about the situation.
It is a formal fact about the
relation of X sits next to Y,
that this relation, which is
instantiated in this world,
in this room, is symmetric
but not transitive.
So it is sort of, there are formal facts.
There are not on the level
of individual numbers
and their properties.
There are at the level of
largely second and higher level
properties of physical
and other properties.
Now, how do you reconcile
this higher level formality
with the fact that we do mathematics,
usually first level in terms
of individuals like numbers?
My own explanation is, and
this is part of what I said
before, how we know the world depends
on our mind and on the world.
It is very likely that
human beings are such
that it's easier for them
to figure out relations
between say, cardinality properties,
when they think about them
in terms of structures
of individuals and their properties,
numbers and their properties,
rather than properties
of properties of properties.
That will explain why we talk
in terms of first order terms,
which is very different to
connect them really to reality.
But they are systematically correlated
to these higher level terms, formal terms,
that it's very easy to
connect them to reality.
So that's how I sort of think that
the formal is in the world.
And I'll just say one more sentence.
That even if you take the physical,
I mean gravity is in
the world, even though
it has certain counterfactual scope.
So just because it holds of
counterfactual physical object
doesn't mean that it's not in the world.
I don't think about
counterfactual situations
as other worlds or possible words.
It's a way to represent
to ourself a certain force
and a certain stability and generality
that some properties have.
So that's how I look at it.
(audience applauds)